a crowd in Hollywood defies the curfew
and faces the consequences but one
protester didn't get away fast enough
there we go
that individual there just went down
this film crew witnessed what seems to
be the impact of a rubber bullet
arresting those who won't obey curfew
isn't a new tactic for law enforcement
in the aftermath of George Floyd's death
but what's significant here in Los
Angeles is how early the stay-at-home
order began the harshest curfew the city
has seen since race riots almost three
decades ago and that's because of scenes
like this
four days now vandalism and looting have
been a distraction from the message at
the heart of these protests a demand for
equality and an end to active police
brutality the president desperately
wants to restore law and order forceful
rhetoric at a time when Americans are
looking for leadership it's about time
somebody took charge and did what
they're supposed to do instead of what
they've done in the past this guy I
don't care what anybody else says he's
doing a fantastic job whether you like
him announcer material he just wants
rule of the land this is not a sovereign
here this is a present this is democracy
this is not we don't have the king and
if we did his head would be on the
chopping block
I mean everyone's just really mad that
black people are being treated so badly
by the law enforcement and this keeps
happening over and over again so this is
why people are rioting and yes we do
need law and order but we need a
different kind of law and order I think
many in the u.s. are getting used to
seeing the military on their street
corners cities and suburbia on high
alert a rapid escalation in just over a
week for a country revisiting tensions
that never really went away
Becky Cottrill Sky News Los Angeles